je teste sur 40 jazz di caro est une
allée poids c'est quoi les carreaux
avait gagné 1 cousine on ne peut plus le
revoir et car en voiture pour gagner vos
bras après que la voiture procréatique
nouba partout donc bon non c'est terminé
tout en même temps
parmi les insupportables il est
insupportable
sur internet c'est juste dieu ainsi peu
un geste rim temps au siége et bleu dès
que je me connecte à thiès comme je
voyais car ou non la une tout le temps h
24 ah mais l'autre jour ils étaient là
je regardais moi aussi je tombe dessus
tu vois je me suis réveillée à deux
heures du mat je n'arrive pas à me
rendormir ah tiens je vais pisser sur
deux chaises comme bayer complètement
fou mais mais c'est bien pas tant mieux
tant mieux tant mieux ça fait ça fait
des stream ça fait des live et il ya du
monde qui regarde que d'un oeil ball en
plus il est trash mais au moins du coup
ça fait un peu spectacle il laisse pas
indifférent tout cas non il laisse pas
indifférent et du coup elle va écouter
non c'est bien et mais nous aussi on est
là tous les jours donc je ricard ou un
mac bien se tenir
c'est au cas où les carreaux et donc et
donc on va se battre se re suivre
l'aréna sa vie y est déjà quelques
inscrits ça le brave au whisky non plus
n'en sait déjà comment ils y passeront
confinement s'il a réussi à
s'approvisionner
ouais ça c'est vrai que c'est pas sûr
ouais moi j'étais en mode walking
premier jour quoi genre je vais chercher
les souffles ait eu à traiter chaud moi
j'ai pas été très prévoyants quoi du
coup mais pas bien ben oui ça va je
ressorte risquer ma ville dans la
semaine comme et pro tu te fais pas
livré bah je sais pas je culpabilise par
rapport aux pauvres livreur non je fais
un dry depuis ce sera celle où wayne
mais je pense que livraison drive
honnêtement c'est le truc j'en sors je
suis pas médecin en quoi mes de ma
vision des choses c'est le truc le moins
un plus à la fois le plus hype parce que
ça enfin moi seul truc qui m'énerve
c'est que face qui mère papa pour
mais bon pour les livreurs c'est pour
moi en fait les livres à devrait juste
être équipés la caravane la base
ouais ils devraient aller de livraison
livraison et au moins tu t'es quittera
un mec vraiment bien et oui ça devrait
être la base
non mais carrément comme ça personne a
besoin de sortir pour faire ses courses
il m'a presque fait beaucoup de taf mais
si l'on oublié des zooms et tourne
normalement sa place oui tu peux avoir
plus de jeanne qui livrent enfin elle
fava un nouveau casque nouveau car les
défauts choco aussi désolé femme et
femme fatale face à ta chevelure quoi
bon aller faire un bon tennis avec
femmes d'ailleurs c'était sympa petit
zoom la whey heinrich bien femmes ouais
franchement j'étais assez surpris parce
qu'il n'est pas hyper longtemps elle a
une bonne frappe carrément ouais ouais
non il a une bonne patate
il ya une bonne patate surtout en coup
droit ouais même temps c'est facile on
génère ya que toi qui est meilleur en
revers qu'en coup droit je pense
ouais nan sérieux mais le revers il
passait pas trop quand on a joué
ensemble
malheureusement on sentait qu'il était
pas loin mais n'était pas étayée il
rentrait pas quoi un effet un peu comme
aux échecs quoi j'ai besoin du rush
c'est j'ai besoin du rush quand le rush
et là ça va mais quand leur jeu n'est
pas là ça le fait pas méthot c'est un
joueur de roche
oui on blâme osé chagossiens d'ailleurs
car amand montrond cher soit j'enchaîne
la victoire tâche commence at-il tempête
gels et il te facile comme tout joueur
de poker
donc du coup dans un sens comme dans
l'autre nan shan victoire ou défaite
fermez la en fait quand je joue c'est
mon travail sur les émotions de chacun
tout de suite comment commence pas ça
t'as pas besoin de regarder la position
au fait tu vois ma gueule et tu sais si
je fume
je le fais volontairement ça me dérange
pas plus d'une fois j'en rajoute un peu
pour que l'adversaire je te monstres là
je dis ce stade alors qu en fait j'en ai
jamais dans ma tête j'ai toujours prêt à
la moindre imprécision à retenir dans la
partie jusqu'au théâtre à des échecs
alors le tueur qui ont vu en profite sa
niche de couples en profitent pour le
dire il nous montre si les batailles de
problèmes sont illimitées pour tout le
monde où j'ai eu un bug non non non tu
as comme la pendant deux semaines ils
ont mis les puzzles rush des batailles
de puzzle gratuite pour tous commencez
vous à partir de lundi je crois que
c'est commencer je crois que c'est
comment d'accord parce que je veux j'ai
traduit le truc vite fait mais très
sympa un gros succès dans mon cas j'ai
pas partagé pour l'instant il ya une
grosse mode du puzzle rush quand c'est
sorti et puis c'est un peu sorti de mode
certes mais surtout leur bataille n'est
pas une fin en soi ça peut être marrant
de delphine de bottes points pour le
faire mais peut-être balance le lien
dans le chat dans une mis le lien déjà
prêt pour je mets le lien pour les le
tournoi du coup fait d'inscrire la
communauté piste rime forcément pour
pouvoir jouer ouais mais c'est gratuit
c'est facile et du coup pour le faire
c'est que comme on roule agente si
jamais ils ne savent pas dans le tchat
on va on va voir on va voir si tout le
monde sait qu'il ya des gens qui ne
savent pas dans la loi ils vont demander
donc aimé en gros ils vont trouver les
liens car on a des gens on a des gens on
a des mandats des jambons mais les gens
vont n'est pas très nombreux pour le
moment mais ça devrait ça devrait
rentrer les gens saturent accès 12h15 by
and to hide eu plus de dow jones qui
lâche je veux tu vois ce que j'ai oublié
de faire c'est de mettre le truc sur la
surface au point de vue ça c'est le truc
que j'oublie parfois mais je vais
rapidement là près d'une seconde
non oui non oui oui gentil non c'est ça
oui
gentiment il est gentil ces derniers
prennent tout ça ouais c'est le prénom
des champions exactement
[Musique]
tant pis on va faire ça à l'arraché
grave ça ça me le voit pas qu'on sait
faire mais on a en vrai jazz comme ils
sont toujours sympas sont toujours sympa
non mais c'est juste ça il ya des gens
qui viennent se connecter sur czech
comme maintenant qu'ils ont pris
l'habitude aussi oui vous jack indirecte
du coup ça leur donne s'inscrit
complètement complètement complètement
mais donc ça parce que tu as enlevé at
enlever tous les voies j'ai tout enlevé
jean ambassades d'avoir maintenant
l'album je les fais non mais tu as
d'ailleurs si on adapte au jour le jour
un petit peu mais du coup tu as prévu je
me disais de de faire de stream tous les
miens 10 ou 13 heures à partir de demain
c'est ça ouais on a prévu ça parce que
c'était prévu comme ça c'était prévu
comme ça et oui j'étais prévu comme ça
de partout en réalité ça me tient
rendez-vous sympa ouais puis au final on
a discuté avec les gars dans le chat tu
vois la fin tout le monde s'ennuie toute
la journée
bah je me rends compte pour moi en fait
ça va tu as j'essaye de me lever à 9
heures le matin petite douche je me lave
les dents petit je me fais des petites
match à le petit matin quand il fait
beau je reste assez genre une heure sur
le balcon ya le soleil jusque là sarah
et sur les coups de 11h30
je commençais un peu tourner en rond je
me dise pasqua et je me suis dit que
tous les gens étaient un peu ce problème
une fois la matinée terminé de se dire
tu vois maintenant on fait quoi
et la voilà le tournoi me dis c'est pas
un moment habituels pour faire les
tournois mais je soutiens ça change un
peu
moi ça me tient rendez-vous sympa moi ça
coïncide plus avec mon réveil mais du
coup c'est bien le chien
ouais tu te réveilles tranquille tu
prends ton petit café battue sera à
partir de 13 heures après à partir de
demain c'est très cher c'est peut-être
le parfait tu peux gagner chez soi
tranquillement les gens qui disent ouais
mais moi je suis en train demande à
cette heure-là plat comme c'est une
arène ça dure une la reine a duré une
heure et lui tu peux venir tu joues deux
trois parties tu peux manger en même
temps tu le manges avant tu peux manger
pendant faire une pause soit voilà tout
le monde se
tout fait sa vie tranquillement mais à
ce point ouais ça permet de se faire
voir un petit truc l'aprem et puis ceux
ci n'ont en fait tu commencé les stream
la part des gens pensent escrime à 17h
18h et on a paradé script sur twitter à
partir 17 18 heures de pareloup c'est
vrai que pendant enfin jusqu'à 15 16
heures tu as rien donc là ça permet
d'avoir voilà quelque chose d'un peu un
peu différent mais c'est un bon moment
tu as raison ça change ça change tout
bon on avait l'habitude avec les
candidats et donc il en a d'autres
candidats viennent d'un certain niveau
de ce que tu vas dié de ce que j'ai pu
voir déjà parmi les inscrits les
français andré je le connais il ya
incognito oui mais c'est un très bon
joueur de club à motta maugrée fallen
gens qui te dire hier ils nous ont un
peu impressionnés était bon ta banane
verte c'est et anne dans le tchat
voyez un souvent les arènes jeudi banane
verte
ouais c'est un bon il ya julien qui a
hier a fait des grosses game donc voila
tu as déjà quatre les quatre premiers
joueurs franchement ça renvoie quoi à
chaud ça joue vraiment ça joue vraiment
et c'est sympa et même derrière il ya
franchement il y avait il y avait du
lait le du level toulon un jeune élève
qui a inscrit seulement mon courage
dernier à l'eau pour l'instant mais melo
c'est juste dans la tête hein since
computing ouais bah écoute il peut faire
des perfs hillary un joueur qui faisait
dire à 2150 il a battu en 1800 il était
heureux pour le 1800 mah aussi mais ça
compte et ça lui marc bonnet ouais bah
faut quand même aller prendre la game
quoi ça dépend du mât ou s'il est
possible
ouais mais bon bah voilà quand même
gagné il était là il était là quoi de
tout il ya le tueur tu aurais yaya toure
tueur du 505
toute chose je vois souvent faire de
chasser la capote masqué c'est moi lui
50 qui a battu le 1800 avec un pseudo
pareil peut y avoir que des bonnes
surprises
il était là où il a patrouillé avec
l'api non c'était sympa c'était sympa
hier c'était très sympa et il ya eu des
pertes humaines partie mais tu vas voir
tu vas tu vas être surpris qu elle
surpris ça je demande 4 surpris moi je
fais une contre 1,2800 et après analyse
n'a pas fait de grosse connerie je suis
1230 grosse perf à la capote masqué
c'est fantastique
j'aime beaucoup ce joueur d'échecs
espagnol même plusieurs j'ai déjà joué
contre aux canaries dans des tournois
qui s'appelle capote ya toute la famille
capote tu peux t'en faire trois dans le
même temps c'est une très très gentille
j'ai pas comment se tient en espagnol
pas c'est à dire la même chose je sais
pas ça veut dire la même chose c'est le
cas ça craint quand même ça pas dû être
facile la scolarité capote
donc c'est vous qu'on s'inscrit alors il
ya le lien et sinon le club ya quelqu'un
qui va mettre la chope notre soumis deux
cuillères et geoff hoon pour le moment
il faut ça peut ça peut arriver avec
leurs yeux genre moi j'aime bien les
gars qui ont les petits risi talent sans
doute
moi j'aime bien le pseudo déjà que
lorsque georges
donc il peut se passer des trucs et puis
soumis du cuir en plus d'amis lui mais
soumis du cuir en plus s'ils regardent
le truc en famille et où il nous a dit
alain foix parfois il est pour la télé
tout est en fait quand j'ai regardé avec
ses parents ses parents habitent
travaillent doivent pas trop comprendre
aux parents boosté par ans condamné à un
poisson dans des délires un peu un peu
spéciaux m
ce mythe du curry sa famille ça c'est un
bon titre admission à sou médical à sa
femme seule avec ses filles de 10 et 12
ans ça va bien comprendre ce que ça veut
dire du coup de pseudo ou est ce vous et
des questions mais ne le font pas ce
qu'ils des bons parents soirée des
parents normaux avec dans une famille
normale
non mais des parents pour développer que
ça les fait pas marrer c'est réservé aux
membres du club liste rim nous d'y
allouer cap
alors si tu peux mettre le lien si
quelqu'un peut mettre le lien je
pourrais je trouver les bons quand on a
un chat de qualité j'essaye de compter
sur elle se repose sur le tartan pour
vaincus rien c'est gratuit suffit de
cliquer participé il ya quelqu'un qui va
te mettre le lien franchement là je sais
pas ce qui se passe si j'avais je vais
le faire un ou sami mais bon on peut
quand même leur position bordel on a le
droit non il ya plein de bonnes âmes
dont ceux chap ok le futur coach s lunch
s d'âmes charitables nuit on n'est pas
bien nombreux les gens ce samedi bah
écoute ça rentre petit à petit après
peut-être samedi c'est les gens qui ont
peut-être aussi gardé une routine de
dire le samedi après-midi ce week-end je
sais pas quarantaine
ça va se faire petit à petit ouais puis
40 c'est déjà pas si mal
des dizaines trois pilotes a quand même
un petit rajout de temps pour t'en
sortiras 27 est un peu rapide pour toi
c'est à peu près l'équivalent de 5 + 0
n'ont au final problèmes de pc fouta
gamme invités de sécurité normalement
c'était vraiment largement gagné ou dari
va-t-on sortir un finir le taf
umberger haricots verts ça j'ai jamais
essayé ouais mais la supérieure je pense
pas qu'ils amarena way de passions qu'on
savait pas que c'était demain ou
dimanche qu'elle voulait pas décevoir
jaeggy dimanche besoin d'avoir un peu ce
qui se passait alors il ya noir pâle qui
propose un mini match du chat contre fo
perez c'est en train de s'organiser sans
rigoler ouais ouais c'est en train de
s'organiser il faut qu'on ait faut qu'on
réussisse à avoir des dates qui ce qui
se bloquent mais ça va avoir lieu ray
robert récents sur rodez n'était pas
content le jour de l'annulation
il a touché toulon il était très énervé
pendant les interviews que j'ai vu vous
prenez pas ce qu'ils disent est donc
celle des records plus frais radjabov
ils ont été respectées bon alors on se
suit à partie ouais c'est parti on
commence par parler par les victoires
mais du coup ça marche comme ça c'est
l'appareil et mahmoud 1 à 1 contre 2,3
contre 4,7 à mal donc ça va envoyer
directement du lourd avec une position
intéressante avec le corps l'occurrence
et 3 la dame peut pas être chassé quoi
ça devient une petite finale directe qui
coupait un excellent joueur de finale
grosse technique
ouais c'est pas du second degré avant
avant ça l'était mais il a gagné pas mal
bossé les villas donc maintenant
maintenant c'est plutôt bien en fait je
joue là pour l'affilié d'or doubs
souvent la finale d'affilée dans
l'habitude qui la font souvent surtout
si tu veux gagner quoi pas sur un pied
qui va venir en c 4 à 5
ouais elle le fou en d6 manque un peu de
gasoil en c5
c'est pas ma tasse il fait quand même à
quatre baies 5 ha qui est de faire payer
ses quatre vingts jours fous au f4
j'aime bien ça
lectures ses 3 mai de 1 4 passes contre
agir ça c'est typique des petits
problèmes pratiques pour la noix même si
ça a l'air très plat très symétriques
tout ça en réalité ils ont des petits
soucis coordonner leurs pièces webcam
via c7 qu'un petit peu faible auquel il
avait pris le cahier des cinq la dette
en mai à 5 finalement se retrouve un peu
faibles ils y avaient leurs thématiques
si la tour bouge on peut manger le cas
bayrou celle ci c'est la somme qui va
tomber les ballons ils sont 0 faiblesses
surtout ça la différence
il vient jouer je pense c'est un petit
peu soulagé la position qu'ils y
arrivent à 8
ouais enfin en tout cas ils forcent les
plans à force de échanges à prouver
quelque chose ok vie c'était vraiment
bien joué ce cadre il pourra jouer mais
si ces cavaliers apsys il aura consolidé
elle joue avec ses 6 j'aime pas trop
denses et sista sony tous un peu table
mais tu veux mais cinq plus tard au
revoir pour émettre le cas durant ces 5
et faire la même oui c'est vrai t'as
raison
non je trouve qu'il a vraiment bien bien
négocier l'aller été très précieux ça tu
vas faire tes idées si c'est une fort de
pousser les changes là est ce qu'on ait
obtenu mon cher qu'elles jouent tour à
deux télésièges s'activer garder le fou
c'est pas faux bond volaille avec j'ai
réfléchi il joue il chauffe ou des six
je pense qu'on va les clichés avec les
noix ou fera voir problèmes physiques
ouais j'ai l'impression que c'est en
train de bien se passer très sain est
relativement plat faut vraiment qu'avec
les français caf 1 parce qu'il peut y
avoir des deux en l'air mais il ya
peut-être du tour b un tour combes et 7
mai avec un k tc3 il peut peut-être rasé
dans ce cas les conséquences seront
ouais il peut raser les trois pions là
c'est joli tailleur est oui
le lait de cavani qui font fonctionner
manière très harmonieuse ensemble
finalement le fait d'avoir le fou ici
bas ça c'est décoratif
je crois qu'il est juste très mal et il
a cliqué dessus pukki poupe qui a beau
son physique de tête de série numéro 1
ouais il est chaud il est chaud
d'attenté b3 roi prend pied en français
cac et prend tour 17
je crois pas trop ce que lyon va casquer
pour 1,4 quoi qu'il arrive
après c'est une fusée quoi en football
le cavalier du pouce à quelle vidéo ses
5 îles
il est bien c'est indéniable et un peu
d'incertitude
ouais toit ainsi ce match peut embêter
mais de rentrer à lille à rentrer là
dedans petit bouton ouais mais ça va
trop cuite du coup c'est mieux pour la
noire très bien joué tour e sata
ouais il intercale tours 7 il est tard
et sa grosse technique en jalles et
maintenant il ya le roi qui s'activent
en fait ya tout pour les norias peinture
plus adroits plus actifs
les pions blancs plus faibles il a
beaucoup d'avantagés
tu nous laisses attend un avantage
décisif du coup on doit avoir un style
qui se ressemblent avec pipe
babu qui pousse généralement il est
foutu dans cette partie
ça se termine bien pour lui j'ai assisté
un homme de partir il était à moins - 5
- 6 qui l'a retour d'aile donc c'est
très variable mais jamais pour répondre
à pau mexicain on sait c'est comme ça
c'est le hasard
non parce qu'il a bien mérité de sud du
coup il a bien drapeau au mexique bon du
coup aucun rapport avec le mexique quoi
très bien voyagé au mexique mais il n'a
pas d'origine
alors du coup je vois depuis trop le
chat le faire ckoi fm c'est maître fide
c'est comme comme sami c'est ça être
mettre la fédération internationale des
échecs sont sacrés titre un ouais ça
rigole pas pour arriver à ce niveau ou
de travail à bas alors ici le fait est
que si on transpose en finale de
cavaliers a du coup il le fit ça on
s'est plutôt bien et que les blancs à
mes camarades au juste il était bonne
mais la partie sur les champs parce que
j'allais dire juste d'un peu plus de
chance de faire annuler la finale deux
tours car la finale de cavale il
exactement
mais à canal ya deux abonde où il va
être dur il va être dur à prendre
notre ami notre avis falloir aller
chercher m
on se regarde un peu des joueurs
amateurs pour changer cavale partis avec
un peu de folklore
allez je remonterai juste l'ouverture
s'est jeté au caire c'est du gros niveau
en 1200 jade et 5 faut connaître c'est
d'un compliqué non plus je suis pas
convaincu la veillée des caps je ne
connais pas oui la cavalerie 6 le couple
à six et quatre à cinq cavaliers à cinq
il ya plein de marion c'est sympa moi
j'aime bien mais plutôt pour les noirs
maire a demandé si la première boulette
de notre ami belge avec les noirs qui se
prend une grosse fourche est d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'il avait prévu c est un bel
moi je serais tombé dans le piège c'est
loin d'être idiot ce qu'il est en train
de faire alexandre suite de trois quarts
a une tête à tête ou demain matin avec
l'image du foot
oui oui sûrement c'est hyper bien ce
qu'il a fait et si j'en parlais un peu
hier c'est marrant dans live t27 frei
liver l'awt race track soeur élise et
qu'en réalité à petit niveau genre les
plans ils gagnent souvent parce que les
noirs connaissent pas du tout mais si tu
apprends une ou deux variantes où il ya
des pièges avec les noirs en réalité tu
peux tu peux te faire défoncer avec les
plans assez facilement fait puisque il
ya seulement il ya un gros jeu de deux
pièces très actif
tu sais que j'ai un peu de mal avec les
doigts ont été très dynamiques et
laroquais mais du coup il va sûrement
perdre ses deux pièces mineurs pour la
toux - adam france des quatre cavaliers
prend la suite d'abus j'évite windham
j'évite les français j'ai même pas ce
qu'est qu'on saison mais c'est clair que
les noirs sont très très bien se passe
bien pour le nord en fait ouais
alexandre alexandre de windows qui lui
dit j'ai passé deux villes de ville de
sûrement c'est toi qu'a voulu m'attaquer
j'ai envie de dire on rentre chez toi
quoi joue pas du tout à 1015 en fait là
bas mais sczesny ils sont ils sont assez
bons et ils jouaient pour pour pour
clore tout débat ça ajouterait
humainement se voyait yarn on trouve que
les vagues juste bien quoi mais là je
suis assez impressionnant a confié très
tactique
c'est un peu ce qu'on a vu hier avec
avec mathieu avec des joueurs pas très
bien que la soeur après qui font des
grosses gaffes de temps en temps
d'accord mais jamais dans les ouvertures
et outils ont des idées tu vois qui
viennent avec des convictions et je vois
des choses un klingon et qui connaissent
leur qui connaissent leur schéma est ce
que vise à mathieu visées sur 13 comme
être mille cent mille deux cents c'est
ça m'a l'air d'être plus fort que 1100
1200 fils tu vois oui oui oui oui je
pense c'est humain
je vois même avec des élèves que j'ai
ouï le décalage est dans ce sens là on
se faisait des compétitions réalisons
[Musique]
clairement ces choses c'est qu'après ça
descende plus bas aussi sur sanchez
comme tu descends à 806 ans alors que
dans l'est lyonnais
elle ne peut pas c'est pour ça que nos
nettement j'ai déjà vu déjà joué ou vue
des parties de gars qui étaient 850 950
jouent entre eux et c'était pas ridicule
quoi peut faire des bonnes parties
s'étaient pas une erreur enfin un coup
une erreur ça fait simplement pas c'est
plutôt de temps en temps une grosse
étourderie ans rennes où il ya un fond
de jeu
ça fait plaisir comme a comme dit loeb
qui reste franchement c'est agréable
mais ça va monsieur sur la droite a tout
est là mon titre et je ne suis rien
d'autre que cette chose là tu as toutes
les infos c'est quand même toit il faut
on peut on peut en profiter pour le
rester mais tu traduis les articles de
chasse comme tu améliores les incite
josé les écrits les arts chip count the
scope en français j'en écris certains et
sinon je prends un peu le souk l'onglet
j'essaie de vous proposer de les choses
un peu plus fluide agréable à lire est
écrit très bien tu as écrit un roman
j'ai écrit un roman que je là c'est la
bonne période pour essayer de le faire
publier justement je m'y attèle web du
coc au matin mon des voix parce qu'il
s'est passé plein de trucs parti vers
une pièce de plus pour les noirs à moins
spectaculaire mais moi qui prend 4,6 le
est la ligue 1 très très fort dommage ça
c'est dommage parce qu'alexandre qu'ils
aient une très bonne partie puisque
c'est un moment donné il ya quelque
chose qui s'est mal passé et c'est
l'enchaînement des gaffes
c'est alors bon ya pas deux
non pas de moyen de s'en sortir ici il
ya tout l'espace frêche c'est fini c'est
fini ça l'udac génère des enchanteurs
ici un roman jeunesse avec cela sonne
plutôt non dit il
harry potter bien sûr et d'ambition
italo divergentes games des choses comme
ça ça te parle
combien de pages sous soir de 220 pages
en format moment ça fait davantage 350
c'est juste le temps un ajustement l'onu
doit attaquer le tome 2 j'ai le temps
d'en profiter
une trilogie a priori si tout se passe
bien et du coup on ne peut pas encore se
procurer il ya quand même moyen de nom
peut pas encore tard je peux le faire je
les fais lui à quelques bêta lecteurs
mais mais non il faut vraiment que je le
bush essayer de leur taille de bons
retours des jeux donnent d'excellents
retours beaucoup très encourageant
jamais un retour d'une maison d'édition
avec qui j'avais déjà que d'aider les
contacts étaient très très bon aussi
très encourageants mais ils font pas de
fantaisie donc ils peuvent pas le monde
défendre mais par contre elle a priori
toutes les tous les ingrédients pour que
ça marche et que ce soit publié tu as
besoin d'eux tu peux aider j'en avais
besoin de contacts avec des maisons
d'édition
donc là je les connaissais mais
potentiellement et c'est à des contacts
ça peut être je peux avoir un ami qui a
déjà publié des livres
après faut cibler wise c'est à dire
qu'il faut que ça puisse correspondre à
ce qu'il souhaite parce qu'en fait les
maisons d'édition seront très sélective
dans le type d'écrit qu elle le propose
il ya du faux b4 l'échec oui piqué sinon
ça n'apportait pas grand chose
mais il aura du mal il va avoir du mal à
développer le que je veux 3 mettre le
feu à des petits problèmes pour les
blancs d'avoir un mât trigolos sur roc
atteint peut aider un des grands vins
cavaliers bkk l'épreuve de maths à
l'étouffée j'aime pas trop qu'il était
fou des 2 et 3 ce qui peut prendre effet
relevé 4 il a perdu un temps pour rien
en fait ouais donc là il est donc dur
notre ami et matt error droit de ce pas
une très bonne nouvelle elle la berd la
boutique là est ce qu'il ya un math un
joli match perso j'y réfléchis la bonne
page facebook 500 francs j'ai deux
chèques de pièces et la guerre qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour lui juste juste
pour revenir ce qui s'était dès 4h et le
le contrebandier albin qui peut être
dangereux et je crois que c'est plutôt
pions prend et des quatre normalement
oui moi je joue de voir sa ville
ouais c'est ça va pas la faire cavalier
seul pour tout cas pour essayer de
récupérer quelque chose oui oui y'a pas
au bled un sénégalais prend des quatre
ne participons pas forcément
passionnante mais n'étaient pas moins
bien 4,5
carrément ok ok bon et intéressant alors
dans les derniers viennent de commencer
on a quoi on a on éventuel gm comptera
stratégie scandinave
on va voir on va voir ce que ça donne un
scandinave tu sais parfois j'ai un peu
j'ai un peu du mal à les commenter parce
que je me perds vite
tiens par exemple c'est parce que jours
avec fuji car je sais que ça existe mais
je la joue pas du tout oula ça c'est pas
bon la mâche un kebab où je pense que
c'est trop tôt je pense qu'il ya une
raison pour laquelle ce que tu peux pas
d'inventaire fou et 2h crois tu que tu
me lâche pas je prends g4 quoique non
peut-être que dans sept ans de la save
your body shop anti originale tous les
jours à midi à partir de demain c'est
plutôt 13 heures bobby exactement non ça
va en fait à l'autre a pas eu le temps
de faire cavalier 4 carélie g3 wave ou
là alors est ce qu'ils vont faire mais
là c'est intéressant je suis comme ça
j'essaie d'en faire mais la dame sur le
long terme alors -3 que j'avais réussi à
la gagner au bout de vingt coups plus
tard
thaksin et à l'accession
voilà contres sanchez nicolas sanchez un
mec qui tilt en fait il était sûr
préparé que jamais jour une connerie
extrait pour éviter sa très belle vache
trois quarts d'heure il allait manger de
la tour moi c'est juste de l'impro j'ai
fini par chauffer saddam mais je savais
que capdordy dans le futur je les fais
parce que c'est tendu mais en france
c'est un match qu'il faut faire super
gaffe les dames prochain ya plein de
variante où ça marche pas parce que
jamais du mal à sortir après c'est comme
souvent qu'il ya des trucs réfuté
surtout quand c'est ton répertoire avec
les noirs ou qui sont pas très bons tu
sais plus comment est futée parce que
c'est tu veux juste pas en fait oui oui
non mais t'as ta a pris une fois il ya
longtemps pourquoi ça marchait pas puis
juste est jamais revenu dessus et quand
l'opportunité se présente dans une
bâtisse au contraire demandent qu'à
répertoire je joue pas des choses très
catholique très théorique
j'ai très longtemps je vais le blog
mardi gemmeurs la mort dans l'âme à
l'accession par exemple partie sérieuse
avec les plans c'est un peu le beau jeu
de sacrifier un tournoi ouverture pour
l'attak
pour y aller j'y ai avec le noir je joue
des systèmes à base d'options de kétou
g62 g72 cdj taire ou parler pour juste
l'arrêt une partie d'échecs
il était monté à combien de temps avec
elle elle au maximum qu un seul chaise
comme ça je joue pas très sérieusement
second quand je joue jeudi suite à une
censure messenger j'ai déjà de voir donc
26le quelque chose oui vrai je me mets
même bien vraiment pour essayer de
gratter un gros lots faudrait que tu
fasses un rod tout 2800 je pense tu peux
le faire si mais vraiment à fond
peut-être c'est possible après c'est
chaud mais deux militants c'est le choix
de 1700 c'est sûr que je pourrais en
étant vraiment bien appliqué pendant un
certain temps prenant l'habitude cette
session c'est difficile 28 en fait faire
un moment donné ou fatales au stress
sommes plus assez dur durant du bas des
gemmes il y avait moins de points le
site hubert à chaque fois après ça
dépend ça dépend des gènes qui jouent
sérieux ils sont quand même plutôt à fin
2009 un taux nettement
il ya plein de gens de petits gm à 26
ouais
des fois non mais des fois ça peut être
chiant genre t'as un mec qui joue
souvent pas sérieusement genre les
nietzsche il joue souvent pas
sérieusement il doit être souvent entre
26 50 et 27 30 mai genre si tu joues le
au moment où il joua la rate des choses
va mais si tu joues voilà un moment où
il est chaud le mec il est très fort il
est très vrai j'écoute les 26 30 je
crois fille tout juste comme ça mais il
est vraiment un petit peu parce que ça
se passe bien pour ta 28 août et tous
les éléments aussi qu'ils s'accordent
ouais moi je dirais le truc vraiment
important c'est de
pas joué de gm qui sont glacées avec le
classement où ils jouent à l'arraché qui
décide de le quitter une section où ils
jouent bien ils se mettent à try hard
way parce que là en fait les mecs plutôt
à 29 53 milles et juste toi tu les
prends quand ils sont 27 quoi et se fait
raser
ouais mais toi tu vas te lécher
plusieurs fois à 28 ans j'ai pu voir
mais la dernière partie avait toujours
un petit peu chez qui t'a 27 95 blessés
par balles c'est l'impression mais des
fois c'est pas parce que tu es chez qui
c'est qui qui jouent moins bien oui
bizarre parfois way parfois au contraire
tout est sens on débat était prêt à agir
gens c'est l'instinct du chasseur tout
c'est que c'est le moment où tu veux pas
laisser passer
après la mieux comme j'ai déjà réussi
deux fois c'est moins stressant mais à
meiway un moment donné il faut un rush
et il faut enfin je suis parce que même
monté à 2007 en fait même même remonter
à 2007 tué hier j'ai un peu je n'étais
pas en grande forme mais j'ai gentiment
galéré quoi 27 c'est pas anodin
pas simple simple en fait des bonds pour
six champs pour icare où je pense que
bay carouge pas cette année je crois
qu'il de ce que j'ai compris il a créé
un contrôle est en fait depuis deux
jours enfin dès que j'ai mis son stream
cinq minutes il s'amusait à jouer dans
toutes ses parties n'importe quoi mais
vraiment et j'ai pas son but c'était de
bouddha 3000 je consomme sens à chaque
partie il a fait 3 degrés ouest
il a réussi deux coups en faisant ça
ouais c'est juste pour dire le niveau de
dingue du cac oui c'est impressionnant
écart où il est vraiment impressionnant
sa vitesse de calcul c'est assez
monstrueux par an produits et ce qui
nous a quand même écrasé
[Musique]
lagarde bacrot et envel merengue qui
sont des jouets coiffard sperme était la
même position parfois il sait pas car en
face il ya mis les shoots sur les
récents événements le facteur
psychologique a joué un rôle déterminant
à maxime parce que maxime juste il a
perdu autant il ya pas de connexion web
après il a été maltraité mal il avait
lavé arnaquer la d'arnaqué mais en fait
même un mec qui est 2009 sur une chaise
comme icare ou 8 mai intel y trouver
large pression en plus ouais mais la
pression mais la passion suivant il fait
le malin après je sais pas ça tenait
rang fusent quand tu contre la wii il te
fait le bangla tu sais qui va se [ __ ]
de ta gueule quand même que tu as envie
de battre celui quoi ouais mais juste à
te rajoute encore une pression quoi là
dans la partie on a enfoui on voit que
le roi noir vient de se faire des
rockets alors c'était bizarre ce dernier
coup droit très vite non la dame
française n'a pas peur voilà enfin ces
deux pas de bluff bien tu montres et
simplement ses duels quoi mais montrant
ces sept on perd 7
je vois un trou j'y rentre quoi mais
c'est dommage parce que si elle est pas
de plomber du prix de fou c'est simple
pour essayer de solidifier après avoir
joué blessé je veux dire dans ce quota
me fermais la colonne et met juste droit
d'en sortir quoi mais aucun des quatre
voies qui vont sacrifier ce sera terminé
là ils étaient un petit peu optimiste
gène 666 grand maître gims et 1100 ah ok
donc là c'est la caf peut-être il peut
faire une grosse game pour l'instant
serre il a joué cavalier des quatre
départs mauvais coup à man
ducasse porte pas mal
côté grand maître gims ce qui m'a
interpellé calice et 6 pensent que ce
serait pas une bonne idée
la macif direct douane plus fort
exercice en fait ouais parce que là du
coup peut-être laissé encore les droits
arrive pas à s'organiser autour ses huit
tours c'est cette maître gims au nord
dans la vague d'attaqués à la dame âgée
de 6 ans faisait bon tellement soulagé
avec les noirs savoir tout faire battait
doute ces trésors ferme ces trois dames
c'est trop tu vas tu encore gagné du
coup le c6 du hockey et un petit raté
son match
par exemple la dame 17 arabes ont fait
tomber vite les dames trois sets
peut-être qu'il est sait si je vous dis
à tous quoi ouais ça gagner
tranquillement parc s'est drogué à ce
jeu dont on peut alors là je ne peux que
supporter le canard en colère en plus
d'un bon pseudo
h3 à se connaître
oui ça traite ses intérêts comme je peux
je peux d'éviter quelques variantes en
activant la grande x et h3 et h3t 5 g4g
six cavaliers 5
ça c'est bien pour les bleus après on va
faire le 6 par exemple et adam l3
qu'arrive la c6 est ici le coup cg 5
sur quels desseins qu'en fait on a du
fou détroit intéressant donc elles des
thèmes sur les thèmes sur elle cette et
ça c'est déjà un très très gros scores
avec le bureau nature
monstres très dur en pratique pour les
normes et du coup ce qui la joue et où
il garde quand même décidé du black ma'a
avec d'un match 4 l'arrivée des menaces
vous croit achètent sur la chine où
croît chez ces thématiques tu mates à
chaque fois même si si je t'assure en
corse on montre juste très bien et la
tromperie son gérant et will hold on n'a
rien mais je mangeais des pièces comme
ça et là manger de pièces justice il a
joué au hockey
nouvelle preuve que le black man gagner
en ligne pour les blancs tranquillement
mais attention car fille nicole non il
ya une pièce de plus pour dans un seul
qu un pion mais bon j'ai accroché il
faut s'accrocher
la du touage trois dames à chis
peut-être faire bouger ça fait 5 c'est
bien joué sur issa par jordan g45 avec
protection récupère et tout ça deux
pions pour la pièce bon t'es foutu si le
blond font pas gaffe mais normalement il
n'a pas fait 5-5
ouais avec 400 des petites choses
pratiques
ouais c'est pas fini mais tu vois tu
feras tu voulais pas sur des sons du
secteur sous la réf 5 c'est vrai que le
problème c'est qu'on puisse y d'aller
purger trois pour projet sis à el manar
et mes amis là ouais là ça va être
groupe 6 j'ai vu une question en tête
dans le chat un truc sur guy rajab
c'était quoi le truc
ouais un tweet mais à fabrice i qui m'a
écrit ce matin il dit ouais tu pensais
du second degré du premier degré mais
pour moi c'était foule
alors c'est quoi j'ai pas vu alors en
gros il dit la solution pour la fidh de
reprendre radjabov parce que tu as cas
de figure où tu penses que tu penses que
c'est un héros qui a vu le truc j'ai une
déconnexion tu penses de c'est un héros
et qu'il voulait jouer qu'ils avaient
raison et du coup tu devrais intègre
était juste web ou alors tu penses que
c'est un génie du mal et qui voulait pas
qu'ils en profitent pour faire un procès
et m et mettre à mal la fidh et tu leur
prends quand même et comme ça tu
l'obligent à jouer et du coup à et du
coup bah du coup a failli obligé de
jouer un truc qui voulait pas jouer de
base et passe pour un con quoi s'il
refuse moi je pense qu'il voulait jouer
quand même après c'était par exemple le
cas de pas jouer n'a pas été une arme
forcément déception pour lui mais dans
l'absolu le choix je sais pas en bus et
en train de traduire son interview très
chiante à traduire d'ailleurs parce que
c'était quand même pas fait pour être
écrit très oral comme texte c'est pas
très fluide
j stellan bien traités a priori la part
six nations il bluffe rajoutait une
couche et dominguez
quand tu commences à citer des gens
comme dominguez du bluff
oui puisqu'il pourrait démentir donc
donc du cool
voilà il ya fait des trucs sérieusement
d'être évident jouer et puis surtout
c'était pas du tout enfin ces
revendications n'est pas de tout but est
assez logique qu'il ait voulu que le
tournoi soit reporté alors après les
gens disent que maintenant cmvm vesle
oui sur le papier c'est vrai que je
pense que d'un point de vue légal
il n'y a plus grand chose à faire mais
moi je pense que oui effectivement j'ai
pas tout en plus je m'habille les
premiers ils montrent même s'ils
n'étaient pas forcément dessaisi acquis
mais elle était quand même aussi date la
bbc malheureusement c'était pas le
qualifier d'un cheveu à chaque fois
c'est clair que ou quelque part quand il
avait sa place dans ce tournoi je trouve
l'idée qu'il s'est qualifié radiant il a
dit qu'il allait peut-être pas participé
oui mais lui dit que c'était du second
degré après alors c'est un second degré
azéri ouais mais c'est ce qu'il dit
alors après c'est difficile de pas fier
le problème c'est que le truc c'est que
c'est possible c'est à dire c'est comme
nous en français on peut faire du second
degré si les gens comprennent pas facile
non il y aurait plus de second degré et
on serait toujours obligé par le premier
degré c'est qu'on n'est plus des êtres
humains dans ces cas là ouais je pense
que ça fait partie du truc donc c'est
difficile de le savoir vraiment
peut-être que l'algérie était un peu au
milieu de toute façon ce second devait
vous le fîtes ouais mais pas si je
reprends ce comme si j'allais reprendre
tout ce que tu as écrit dans tous les
tchats comme c'est souvent la plus gros
et je veux dire à un moment donné at a
dit ça c'était pas du second degré est
bon quand même
je pense qu'il a le droit au bénéfice du
doute là dessus quand bien même toutes
façons tu as le droit de dire j'ai pas
envie de jouer et puis tu participes
quand même enfin ça peut évoluer aussi
après la coupe du monde est petit à
petit finalement il se dit ok pascal une
chance il a pu se motive au fur et à
mesure ça a pu évoluer
oui oui pas ancré dans le temps un
instant on lui pose la question
ça fait par exemple le grand galop il a
jamais dit qu'ils étaient motivés pour
le tournoi oui et pourtant il jouait
alors qu'il a fait conclut fièrement
qu'il en avait pas grand chose à faire
il vous l'exploit reporter même dans les
parties en plus l'impression qu'ils sont
fous en fait on se constitue de jeu où
dans le monde et finale laisse même
femme
jean gagnon techniquement assez
facilement du fait de la guerre
l'impression wicked et et je reprends la
tête ailleurs mais qui toute façon
maintenant c'est plus possible de
rentrer gros tournois alors le truc si
tu vas prendre des avocats et que
peut-être que le tournoi était illégal
en russie et là dans le cas où
parce que bon on a quand même le truc
comme il l'a dit et ça a été confirmé
par cramique d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'il a pas commenté
d'ailleurs c'est là une des raisons
invoquées par cramique c'est quand même
le 16 mars le ministère des sports russe
a interdit la tenue de toute compétition
internationale sportif sur le territoire
de la fédération russe et donc il se
trouve que le ton a commencé le 17 avril
on vous dira qu'il a commencé le 15 mai
il n'a pas commencé le 15
très clairement il a commencé le 17 la
première ronde était de 17 salles entre
comme traiter avec sa cérémonie
d'ouverture qui étaient à quai avaient
lieu justement parce que telle ait dit
que oui déjà la technique alors d'elle
même cette cérémonie avec d'un mille
plus de 1000 personnes qui étaient
agglutinées les unes à côté des autres
alors que fadel commencé à observer une
certaine distanciation
oui oui donc il ya ça et donc c'est vrai
que pour moi ci prend cet argument là en
compte que il fait une demande au tas
souvent réussi aux mystères et qui dit
en fait le tournoi il était illégal dans
ces cas là je pense que c'est ça va être
son axe d'attac pour être réintégrés ça
va pas être de dire je vais être
réintégrés au tournoi parce que la fidh
a eu tort à mon avis on axe arrête de
dire le tournoi tête qu'il a eu lieu
n'était pas légal ouais mais pino
absolue si ça va être très long c'est
des batailles juridiques en plus dans
l'état actuel des choses ne peut pas
forcément trop entrer là dedans donc les
principales priorités
je sais pas trop ce que ça va donner les
derniers tous les 1 maxime façon
maintenant il a sa place sur sa ceinture
vois pas de scénario il pourrait externe
paraît complètement impossible c'est pas
possible par contre le scénario ils
doivent reprendre à neuf est possible il
ya un autre scénario possible aussi
qu'on avait évoqué sur la chaîne à notre
avis après on sait pas mais c'est comme
au foot c'est le truc de la saison
blanche c'est juste d'annuler tout
bonnement est tout simplement les
candidats du coup il faut reprendre les
qualifications de zéro et s'est du coup
si tu fais saison blanche c'est comme
dans les autres sports c'est le sait le
précédent à coeur des candidats qui est
de nouveau vainqueur donc ça refera un
madrilène caruana
[Musique]
par exemple tous les cas la fidh est
vraiment dans la merde c'est sur un plan
et c'est sûr dans tous les cas ils ont
très mal géré le truc et ça leur tombera
forcément dessus d'une manière x ou y
oui c'est des gens ne vous réussit est
juste pas quand tu pourras jouer deals
mais qu'il était capable de faire une
série d'invincibilité sans parti là ils
jouent à la passe en fait son niveau de
jeu sur le tournoi tu ouvres faisait de
la peine quoi c'est tellement la mecque
a l'air tellement gentil vente a trouvé
qu'il arrive de mal traîné sa peine
parti à parti un peu triste ils se sont
mis vraiment parce que du coup ces mecs
là bas aussi il on lit bien sûr ils ont
intérêt en fait il que maxime et dépôts
j'espère que ça reprenne exactement au
savon et eh oui donc je sais pas après
quel point ou cadres a dit on verra on
verra mais c'est finalement j'ai recruté
une interview de voir kovic fait pour le
championnat qui est un genre
d'équivalent de l'équipe en russie ouais
un peu moins gros mais on va dire un peu
dans le même esprit et il dit clairement
qui va pas réintégré radjabov ça c'est
ce qui dit maintenant l'objet tenir ce
discours pour l'instant tant dans le
chat qui soupçonne stockfisch de s'être
invité parmi les participants nous pour
avoir suis fan depuis hier en tout cas
on suit vraiment les parties à fond on
n'est pas encore tombé sur une seule
partie
mais je suis d'accord moi je vois
souvent des accusations de triche
une fois dans le forum là deux fois sur
dix justes baddou mais quatre jours joué
il a fait des conneries aussi là ça peut
arriver mais ça reste vraiment pas la
norme atteint exemple les clubs l'ont
ils trichent pas
loria georges e tour des 3 c'était pas
le coup le plus glorieux de sa carrière
quand même dommage parce qu'il avait ts2
[Musique]
je vais essayer de faire marcher un
pacte vote serré à droite version v6 prg
petit ces contrats j'aime et j'ai fait
ma femme dont j'avais les noailles il
m'a même pas tu es donc j'avais deux
dixièmes ou rim abate j'étais très
heureux a tué tout est beau hasard et
plaisir ça alors est-ce que hong kong
ait vraiment vite fait ouais c'est
pendant ces julien un an
il a joué une partie plus elles veulent
une partie de plus donc c'est flou c'est
la difficulté des arénas en fait c'est
que souvent il suffit pas à t on peut
regarder julien terrain une fin de
partie là le leader d'al les plombs ça
va complètement nul on est complètement
nu et loïc parce que là tu t'es un
blocus mêmes gens qui ont des cistes
d'ailleurs trois secondes contre ou là
oui oui ça va gagner du coup bah voilà
annoncé les quatre mais trois secondes
c'est très dur la jet set j'ai six
pattes et non je pense que c'est un beau
coup mais pratiquement avec trois rondes
qui peut créer des problèmes ça que je
veux dire et souvent je remarque aussi
cassis voilà déjà un petit problème
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas toujours
confiance en leurs techniques en finale
ouais alors que ça ta meilleure chance
et c'est sûrement de leur équipe et donc
trop de pression de julien qui jouent
bien le jeu de l'aréna parce qu'en fait
il faut tout tempo pour jouer plus de
temps les autres tu prends moi je le
fais souvent aussi quand jeune quand je
fais les arénas et pas que la line up
c'est pierre houde jeannard au disque
hikaru enfin tant chaîne et [ __ ]
fiables et non comme ça mais il ment une
bonne technique s'est essayé de rouler
vite pour les éviter c'est de marquer un
maximum de points fin tu prends des
risques en fait
voilà mais je pense que sa maman était
un peu obligé julien c'est un peu sa
stratégie dans son oreille ça paye par
contre quand tu te rates s'est très vite
fini oui là du coup la banane verte
contre bourgoin c'est une belle affiche
aussi quand même la capote m'assieds qui
nous prévient que dans 5 minutes ça ils
rentrent dans le game à la capote
masquer tous aux abris
wihr oms qui dit mais non mais c'est un
super tour 2416 comme effectué une bonne
partie des accusés trichant prix change
serait pas 1400 je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi et puis il faut juste
laisser lighters conséquent c'est comme
ça et puis cet empire
ils font du guide fond d'une petite
dobro vie touchait pas comment appeler
ça t'es au courant de cette histoire oui
ça me dit quelque chose
j'en avais coller une bella d'oberhof
dans une arena je m'étais manger le
petit malade comme pour faire balmont
compte en toute détente et de branches
en plus ce jam subissent chaque fois
avec lui c'est vraiment le mec tu sens
qu'il est mauvais perdant qui ragent
qu'ils font chez eux qu'ils naviguent
joue pas toujours très sobre
oui mais bon il ya aussi une petite
réputation de peut-être pas être très
très cher
moi j'avais pas trouvé du tout
impressionné avec lui sans doute parce
que je trouve pas que je me suis perdu
non mais après moi je regrette pas mais
il n'est pas bien placé pour le faire
mais pour donner des leçons
particulières par la queue
c'est un peu comme blitz match 1-0
mi-temps le title tune de jeu débattu
j'ai pu finir avec six sur dix par là
que c'est exactement 3 me si je crus je
les gagne tous quoi les stats absence de
faire répondre oui et je voulais bien
n'était pas bien placé dans le sens où
lui lengagne de temps en temps ou s'il
ya quelqu'un sur lesquels on doit avoir
des doutes entre lui et moi il me semble
que c'est plutôt celui qui en gagnent de
temps en temps effectivement c'est un
argument aucun avocat andré en
considération et donc ça rejoint
exactement ce que disait si je parlais
de ça c'était pas pour recouvrir une
petite mais c'était pour dire à bibis
remix bah tu vois ça arrive à tout le
monde et j'ai l'impression que c'est pas
toujours les plus clean qui qui font les
plus qu itunes est votre droit mais une
partie assez assez intéressante
un cri fils de matériel de part et
d'autre on voit bien que toujours au
centre mais ce qu'est la mm100 qu'il
fait à ses réserves après les deux pions
plus bas à temps il ya d'aucune plus
alors qu'il a sacrifié une pièce noire
la balle avec thé blanc et il est très
dangereux
la russie progresse mais c'est pas fait
encore parce que hockey et quelques
trouées
je vois un monde dans lequel où les bleu
et noir absolu et ça j'ai dit y'a pas de
maths
ouais y'a pas de maths ouais bah match 5
tu reviens et du coup la défense et
souffrances de manière très naturelle
ok alors voir ce à broadway
ça ne devrait lui pas des sabres de ré
ah ouais ça j'aime bien son pseudo moi
j'aime bien hongrie dunk
ouais bah c'est le joueur de blagues
marie laure de blacks ça fait un beau
duel et on va essayer les îles et
diamants ah oui y'a tout paul alors toi
qui a traduit un peu les leçons chaz com
enfin moi je les fais l'audio mais toi
qui l'a fait aussi un peu le voile a pas
énormément mais un tout petit peu en
attendant tu en penses quoi alors est-ce
que tu recommandes pourrait carrément je
pense vraiment très bon aussi à un très
bon outil de progression par rapport en
fait aux leçons qu'il existait avant il
ya eu beaucoup de travail qui a été fait
pour rendre les exercices des vidéos
plus accessible plus fluide pour qu'il
ya un accompagnement emplettes virtuel
même si y'a pas et qu'un physique ce
manque est là pour vous expliquer à
chaque fois que vous proposez un coup
dans les exercices ya toujours un
message qui adaptés à chaque coup
c'était un truc génériques
donc c'est ludique haussier je poserai
donc c'est bien de s'adapter c'est
progressif selon les niveaux
si vous pouvez posséder finale du tout
un peu les joueurs tu m'as envoyé un peu
de tout donc je pense que c'est un très
bon outil sera pas remplacé par exemple
un entraîneur sur le long terme
mais c'est sûr que c'est vraiment faire
des progrès avec ses leçons
oui je trouve que le rapport qualité
prix assez bon parce que souvent on me
demande si c est ce que je te recommande
d'acheter un livre etc et les livres toi
tu préfères autant que moi ça reste soit
dans la bibliothèque
oui bah tu l'as acheté des contente et
excitée terrain sur tous les tubes du
feuillet t puis après il a senti plus
aux oubliettes
tu fais pas réellement et alors que là
tu peux tu peux commencer déjà avec un
abonnement à 25 euros et monte petit à
petit en gamme suivant comment tu
l'utilisés au final 25 euros c'est le
prix d'un livre et là tu as un truc un
très complet avec l'analyse des partis
parlent avec l'analyse ôté partie par
l'ordinateur sociaux g talents combinés
whip it à tout départ
ça fait deux euros par mois et offrir
des cadeaux de sic donc
donc moi je trouve que c'est pas
vraiment j'ai recommandé à plusieurs
élèves c'est bien aussi de faire des
exercices techniques un petit peu si
vous voulez progresser ce que les
parties elles se joue très souvent sur
une tactique malgré tout jusqu'à un
certain niveau en tout cas
[Musique]
malheureusement ou heureusement mais
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup comme sa
[Musique]
tactique alors la hongrie des petites
menaces sur les recettes et sur le
cavalier ou 2,4 ok c'est pour les noirs
oui nature le long des 4 et un peu
faboulous y ait deux fois et c'est
toujours un gros truc ça risque que tu
fais ces cinglés et blanc tonné la casse
des 5 mai pour ta pas trop axé la classe
disponible ses 5 îles
moi je veux bien le croire oui oui c'est
5 le truc c'est que lui tu te connais tu
avais pas que ça à des 6 es tu donner
des trucs mais tu contrôles et 17 des
six essais de manière très concrète pour
attaquer le roi ne peux pas te prendre
c'est simple parce que des cas très
faible on chez ces cinq d'autant plus
mais bon typiquement toute façon c'est
le genre de position quel que soit ton
choix tu vas faire dénonciation
différentes peut être quatre cinq ou
n'en fout des 6 3 sur
5 il fait juste à chis je sais pas alors
c'est ce qu'il a joué ça peut pas aller
pour les bleus je pense qu'ils peuvent
essayer des tours j'ai trois années
qu'outre jeu baisser à priori assez
artificiel dans l'absolu mais ça n'a pas
t d qui auront un cavalier je crois plus
à la mecque 4 pour presser là dessus du
coup si on fait quatre ans qu'il ya
plein de trucs qui galicien mont des
cats qui gagne 4 ayant plus la dtn de m
du coup en bas donc tu as dame a pris la
gaze du roi donc ici à bâle le canard
qui sache une nouvelle fois très en
colère à prendre mais là bas et fait la
leçon à tous les coups il a fait reculer
le son à fond et ça a rejailli sur son
niveau de jeu
ouais ça se voit on voit la différence
alors entre halliche à aller chasser un
fidèle et la petite pas forcément c'est
un bon ya pas de doute là d'affaires à
l'élite de la nation
c'est une question sur les titres
c'était quoi je rencontre maître
international master fm et dupang scène
m -cm an dernier je crois candidat m ce
doit être le titre le moins élevé voilà
un titre d'ailleurs et quand je me sers
la fit d'ailleurs c'est au moment où ils
mettaient un peu tout ça oui pas où ils
mettaient en place mais oui développer
tous ses titres de
maître national et candidat m et en
réalité vu de france n'ont pas trop à
quoi ça sert mais ça sert pour les pays
je me rappelle avoir lu des articles des
machettes requis pas ces gens le
honduras il était super heureux tu vois
ce que des quiz à des plus de 6 serait
comme ça bah ouais parce que sinon ils
ont zéro titre et de rien et là ça a
créé un engouement ça motive les gars
progresser et donc c'est vrai que vu de
notre côté franco français ou européens
entre 10000 kms et des titres un peu en
carton mais après quand tu prends des
pays où les échecs sont moins
développées ça prend tout son sens l'un
sur une poussée jeunes que j'ai créé ça
on s'en fout ça nous impacte simple de
son compte en tant mieux mais en fait
c'est comme ça y'a des trucs comme ça où
quand tu les vois bien tu de loin tu dis
ouais c'est complètement débile et tout
ça est en réalité une raison bon après
il ya aussi la raison se faire de
l'argent mais à mais juste un peu il ya
quand même un vrai argument qui qui se
tient vraiment moi ça va retrouver les
maîtres phil oui en fait de la seule
condition droite battre kid c'est
d'avoir atteint les 2300 vélo même la
virtual bout qui penche une fois et
après tout petit en titre il n'y a pas
besoin de faire de normes et 7 sera donc
c'est plus facile dans l'absolu c'est
dur et facile à la fois en fait virer
comme m et voilà des points 2-2 à quel
âge tu commences aussi le plein de
choses juste investi dans le jeu c'est
comme les ceintures les arts martiaux
l'origine au japon il n'y avait que la
blanche et la noire et voilà c'est un
peu cet esprit là aucun intermédiaire ou
cinq pas tant il se passe quoi te
trouvais ça yadan hu elle est bon la
main vitry ça te la différence m'a fait
la diff 1 il a fait la diff
ouais mais bon s'il avait mis la main en
guise rim os ils auraient ils auraient
vu c'est sûr je joue chez
pour l'instant je vous chez moi du coup
comme beaucoup mais c'est non et je joue
pour le club de lesparre dans le médoc
région ouais ils sont très sympas base
de bonne soirée
c'est très cool mais qui dans la pente
très très cool un point c'est déjà bel
et je vais appeler mon président pour le
pour le motiver
puisque en plus ils organisent toujours
plein de trucs rêve donc c'est possible
que ce soit à ce parce que c'est comme
tu peux avoir
j'en profite aussi pour lui on sent un
peu plus pour tuer ce n'est pas lui mais
rien pour ça mais mais vous avez le
pouvoir réaliser des matches entre clubs
et c'est super bien fait brain conçu
avec la team france le machin et tous
leurs modèles on a le match contre
l'azerbaïdjan ce soir ce soir
ah ouais on a perdu m'échauffer de quoi
ah ouais ok on prend 17 mai à oui il
faut que tu veux c'est là c'est la
boulette
mais ces championnats d'europe s'est
passé pas le fameux match contre le
pérou dimanche prochain il sera très
important mais quand même à gagner
j'ai juste deux bulles est contre la
serbie - dimanche dernier c'est tout il
était durable je contrains j'aime et oui
bien sûr il paye le déplacement où ils
prennent tout en charge
ce sont des amours mais donc du coup
pour en revenir au sujet beau sujet que
je voulais apprendre à mener c'est par
rapport au match je préfère des matchs
voulez vous créer un club chaise comme
de votre club vous pouvez organiser un
match contre un autre club ça et c'est
assez facile mais ça c'est certain tout
avait bien qui fait le truc contre la
serbie le bullet c'est marrant c'est
sympa mais en plus c'est bien foutu et
c'est facile pour organiser les clubs ne
s'est pas l'article sous la main mais
j'avais écrit
j'avais jamais traduit un article où il
ya des mamans toutes les conseillers en
fait les étapes étape par étape comme
mon père j'ai très facile il pouvait
même le faire c'est pas un club juste
entre potes ou et c'est pas forcément
des sujets classiques vous pouvez faire
d'autres varier autant vraiment faire un
petit peu ce que vous voulez c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment cool à ce n'est
pas vrai là comme ils font la team
français leur système il est pas mal ils
font trois matches et puis après ils
prennent le résultat de individuellement
chaque match comme ça ils font 3 cadence
ils font bullet blitz et et semi rapides
quoi oui je donne c'est complet la dame
il n'a semblé voir pas seul et que la
dame pourrait être enfermé aussi with
you quand nous conte might be
mais peut-être qu'elle s'est échappé à
cinq
ça commence à faire cher c'était un peu
difficile mais glorieux georges
c'est dommage épousa une belle perf à
gloria george and ont séduit comme en
série qui sévit chez la dame lors on
peut camper à aller on essaie de
chercher une grosse surprise
est ce qu'on peut trouver les hausses
surprises dans cette partie là je veux
faire partie aujourd'hui est ce qu'on va
chercher la paire de l'est ont cédé aux
blancs l'os est ce qu'il peut faire
nation une petite normalement oui way là
il a ses chances il a ses chances il a
ses chances 1200 et ça peut ne pas
donner de pièces la joue et des quatre
cavaliers ces trois ou plus c'est à dire
parti s'est trompé au troisième coup
même ce qui va remettre le carré de se
libérer ces quatre revenir en c3 ça
serait un bon plan n'a pas beaucoup
d'autres en même temps au genre de
position
[Musique]
plus agréable à je pourrais avoir sa
peau c'est pas après oui mais c'est que
je décerne sykes et noir mais oui c'est
avec les noirs que tu plus d espace
internet compte déjà fait avec les blu
ray effectivement high as tu pas
peut-être te faire un tacle f 104 4 2
contre jeu en fait c'est pas grave de se
faire attaquer si on peut réagir au
centre mais là je suis entré
complètement faire d'abord f3 je pense
que c'est plutôt bien il me tenait la
main tu dois faire là 4 la place est
vraiment une chance de servir ou pas la
laisser passer
et après j'ai trois dames ici qu'avait
lieu de tubes blindés des normes n'ont
pas si dur que ça parce que fastidieux
que sa tête eut contesté voit la tête et
d'échangé massivement tameka tu sais pas
idiot mais peut-être pas d avis c'est
bien il va te prendre des cases blanches
des casa del à la donne
la droite manière générale ouais t'as
joué cavalier eu deux filles avec là
c'est un peu chier qui a menti ramène à
l'étouffée face pour f4 pour f1 qui les
changent mais je pense que tu as raison
ce n'est qu'à sa tête être ok rien pas
qui a rédigé café genre très mal genre
les catalans très très bas ce que tu
prends pas le set sur échec
malheureusement du coup bah ça gagne la
partie cavaliers ne l'a pas fait a pas
vus et réussi à faire ces quatre jardins
de 7 a été bien cette d'amendés 6 7 mai
toute façon il peut pas rentrer je peux
un petit visage qui visait la case h4
tous étaient bien placés évidemment il
est vrai organisme moins bien voilà
écrivain il a bien bloqué et d un c4 et
c3 ça c'était vraiment bien joué marie
met la pression sur ds 5 10 en plus ça
ça illustre encore plus pourquoi dabo
cet été un peu plus tard
oui vraiment fait peut-être la jeune
fille on prend qui comprendra des cinq
voix ouais c'est toi quasiment avec les
blancs qui commence à trouver du jeu
quoi donc la csq ou de cavaliers un
chien qui va pas du tout quoi
ouais il vise zéro occase
ce qui fait tout est changé
si les changes to egypt être mieux la
tour prend et d'un dessin maintenant oui
c'est des sens qui est un peu faible
alors que peu 3 est difficile ou
attaquable pourra jouer cavalier absent
sur le premier mais oui ça fait plus mal
mais ok je défends l'ofs triche dans ces
cinq ans menace m'attend et fluide ça
peut passer
les dames c'est vite aussi il ya des
dames prend à cette dame seule il y aura
sûrement qu'à l'allier f5 sur 2005 mais
ce qu'on n'a pas du g4 quelle est la
puissance 4 à 6 7% qui n'est pas pris et
la bce bon il a encore un peu de temps
alors à 3,5 modeste alpha 0
la conception est trop profond pour nous
je vais peut-être revenir avec la dame
mais c'est une telle partie 2
il a mal agi début de partie possible
pour les blancs puis s'est bien remis
dans les vingt mille deux cent quand
même bon il ya des erreurs évidemment
mais tu vas y a quand même il ya eu
quand même le cavalier d un c4 qui
essaient 3 qui a fait plaisir
d'accord c'était bien une bonne bonne
bonne heure on à la capote masqué qui
est très fier
labatut patator julien 1800 dont et
chaud et chaud qu'un pas de pascal bats
je crois que t'as pas de masque est il
en train de se révéler au plus haut
niveau a laissé un bon c'est un bon pari
là le seul c'est vrai que c'est
difficile à avaler un regard le piège
regarde sa liste non je crois je sais
pas si c'est volontaire ou pas bien cher
papa ou de tout intermédiaire à 100 qui
fait mal ouais
l'arroseur arrosé mais faire dam des
trois cavaliers la tour 20 et qu'il
prend 24 là là et commence quand même
être dit fisher wes caracas et 4 passes
et vous que j'adore la pagode va scruter
les échos fusse t elle est et du latran
où l'accueilleront destrac ces emprises
quelquefois c'est un scoop je crois
qu'il va avoir des preuves 3 mais très
mou d'un point 3 way ou là je parle trop
d'émotion d'un coup non mais franchement
c'était passionnel il a craqué à la fin
et c'est ce qu'ont fait un petit point
sur le classement pour voir si c'est
toujours aussi serré on regarde on sur
onze étaient très très chaud ouais ils
jouent contre mkd player ci ce qui hier
était dans les leaders il est un gros
tournoi et que rares du
34e
on voit en gris de la huitième des shows
à regret dacquois il est bouillant
[Musique]
il est bouillant banane verte bananes
vertes il va arriver quoi il a dupé du
rail est elle un peu comme julien lui
les à 8 sur 8 mai banane verte qui est
dans une stratégie de jouer vite
j'ai déjà du coup de pouce que tout
aussi vrai possible membres platique
juin
tu as quand même beaucoup de gens je
vois dans le tournoi il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont dès la sortie de deux ans
en fait ils ont aussi truc c'est vrai je
peux dire c'est que je veux dire c'est
que c'est vrai les travaux visant le
truc
l'inde a fait stresser le tour est happé
une bonne partie à l'offre oui à utah
jazz - t'as craqué à la fin mais bon
quelque 200 pièces comme sont adaptés
pour les enfants voient carrément
franchement oui pour le coup le
vocabulaire employé est assez simple je
pense que oui en tout cas les leçons les
premiers niveaux débutant intermédiaire
après ça dépend aussi du niveau de
l'enfant mais mais ces détails comme
chicoine j'avais prévu il faut penser
quand c'est pour ça je vous parlais pas
de pousser les patates des huit ans
qu'il a dû rater d'anne decis comme à
jouer ça du coup maintenant
donc moi j'aime bien le noir
après tout dépend si tu peux organiser
il veut ouvrir la corne de kodak a du
sens pour les blancs là maintenant
fou de cases blanches il va cruellement
manquer je pense ces moments j'avais
lors d'y aller mais je pense que 4
c'était vraiment le seul cours et pour
jouer sans jamais faire quelque chose
après b3 bafoue ses six doigts de finir
comme ça a beaucoup de mal à défendre
donc à la f3 et des clous et en fait des
5-6 même attendre yaya toure projet 3
samat la marche peut-être pas des 5500
fait voir juste par curiosité
ouais c'est un jeu mes lordi en même
temps c'est sûr que nous nous approchons
d'un schéma il défend or h
l'alliage de voyages aériens
c'est complètement fini autour du cou et
au bluff book et ça a marché
droite pour mk déplaire c'est la grosse
bertha une interview
c'est dommage j'aurais pu faire chuter
le leader
oui là il avait vraiment il avait
vraiment tout pour lui un peu trop
confiants booky wook quoi l'homme proche
4-way bas de façon il allait rater dame
betty c'est tout il ya un peu aller
ailleurs voilà je suis plus fort que
vous j'ai pas besoin de calculer
tranquille de chez tranquille alors on y
entre olivier d'aimer this alors j'ai
comme l'impression qu'ils aient pris
quatre c'est pas terrible
les six et des quatre essais stricte et
aux ricains qui donne un pion plus
olympio
pas récupéré ouais du coup été heurtés
au rideau le deuxième coup tigresse au
show king is sur tille à scania aucune
vidéo en français c'est dommage à 6
alors là alors les leçons déjà sur mon
français
premièrement et puis toutes les vidéos
que les cabines toute façon pas toujours
directement sur une chaise comme mais à
chaque fois on en fait la pub dans tous
les articles par exemple sur les
candidats et les des vidéos en français
les analyses de de mathieu de fab des
partis les directs des directs les
amants français rien pour blue de
direction c'est pas ce qui manque
ne pas regarder au bon endroit zaz ou
non il ya beaucoup de noms là les leçons
surtout surtout la section leçon là les
allées elle est très intense
là il ya un nouveau truc en plus mais
c'est en train de 80 du ca par le temps
c'est un peu léger
il ya eu le film joué la comme beckham
s'est jouée la com ladver voilà comme si
rouge à queue et s'est traduit en
français ça puis peut pas tout encore
bay les deux joueurs que j'ai cités oui
donc là on vous prend des parties de
champion vous mais la position par
exemple après ouverture s à vous
d'essayer de reconstruire la partie
c'était un petit avec des conseils les
aides oui j'ai essayé de le faire j'ai
trouvé aucun coup c'est un peu aussi
j'ai décidé que je faisais pas et le
[Musique]
management est amusant c'est quand même
des partages numéro un sur les arénas de
chasse comme je crois que c'est le
nombre de victoires dans le tournoi et
anne ça ferait pouce de mémoire mois la
presse et pas fait encore parce qu'il a
il a 11 points d'avance pour pub mais
c'est super le strict tu perd gagne que
2 points lui qui prend aux tripes ça
peut aller très très vite puis until
they aussi c'est un gros tilt à s'y
perdre
il peut tout perdre
voir connaissent eux arrivent à le
battre avec ses riffs cet appareil est
contre lui
oui c'est ça tue le temps qu'il a parié
serait comme de jour j telle marge
ça devrait aller mais voilà c'est tout
chaud et si tu vas voir l'estuaire être
sûr d'avoir les vidéos en français il
faut que tu règles dans paramètres
surface et quoi vous attendre à tous les
articles en français les vidéos fin tous
et en français tout ce qui peut l'être
le cela simplifiera la vie
non je ne suis pas préparé avec radjabov
il ment bah non en fait n'ont ils pas eu
ça lui suffit de dire d'abord vaseuses
pendant ce temps on à olivier bon c'est
pas clair en fait encore il est quand
même bien tueurs du fou g5 les pièces ne
sont pas le placer à l'option hachette
qui traînent çà fait fab en fait le
tweet de karuïa keane parce que mendier
veut que radjabov soir fonctionnement
qui fait partie de son équipe et que le
tournoi repartent de zéro bien
évidemment vu qu'il fait après la petite
solution mais en fait il appel la
décision de la fidh de faire jouer les
tournois semi légal et donc ça fait très
mal parce que nous on dit toujours
soumis à ses chefs y passe à l'ego plus
parce que ça a créé la femme me dit
encore une preuve que cariat qui suit la
chaîne certainement mais non mais
clairement clairement il est aussi pour
un oui pour une annulation en fait pure
et simple c'est qu'il n'ya pas de bonne
solution être maintenant que le ton art
est à la moitié
quelle que soit la solution il y aura au
moins les extras dans tous les cas rien
juste pour au moins une personne donc
des profiteurs projet si ce salaire oui
bah il a fait
normalement c'est aussi ouais mais bon
moi bien il n'y a pas de compensation
pour laquelle les deux fosses dominé par
le cavalier effectué c'est de prendre g5
et de faire un blocus sur blanc hommes
ouais merde la salle est difficile oui
oui tu as raison était gagnant mais
avancer au centre mais ça pouvait enfin
ça pouvait dire ce que tu nous disais
zou c'est bizarre voir mon travail dans
le son ma tête yves adam vidéo alors
qu'il fallait dans le son et faute
actuel d'environ 7 pouces fauteuil dans
le son encontre et man leçons mais c'est
en fait à l'homme était déjà le bon lien
ouais maintenant elles font elles sont
bien ces leçons ouais j'en mieux que
celles d'avant il un gros tas fond ouais
avant c'était pas mal mais
comparativement comparativement à ça ça
complètement complètement changé ou là
ou alors à tiens ya le match retour
puppy poupe la seule chose que le sommet
tu as vingt minutes donc du coup là
c'est le moment ou jamais s'y perd pas
celle-là cela s'ils gagnent c'est c'est
fini même si à mon avis c'est plus ou
moins fini mais bon mais bon on va dire
que non pour qu'un peu de suspens
exactement mais si canicule tournoi il
aura vraiment été formé la province à
100% les blancs ça c'est l'accession et
et adrien demuth qu'avaient les blancs
contre qui j'ai l'impression qu'il avait
une grosse poubelle en direct forcément
du coup leur en fait
en fait oui c'est bien pour les bleus
alors là je sais pas du tout à quel
point ils ont suffi si les
recommandations ici c'était jusque là
ouais il y avait la partie entre y est
fait l'eiu shirov je serai plus là quand
ils se sont copiés c'est à peu près ça
ah oui c'est vrai que c'était ça c'est
drôle enlevé jeudi où je sais plus qui
la déchire ouais les shirov car yakine
dans le truc de relief est le quatrième
c'est un chinois je rappelle plus
qu'elle oui non non non pleine pente et
you who aussi loup mais mon hockey place
à leur coût total pour lève je sais pas
en fait
j'allais dire pour les noir sans même
avoir des fous et de cavalaire leucate
il est un peu bizarre
ouais c'est que je joue j'ai deux chiens
qui étaient peut-être tenter dé 5 les
celle-ci se barrer je crois que t'as pas
trop le choix en fait ouais ok tu en as
quand même tour aux 8es à ok non c'est
compliqué encore appris aux quatre oui
moi aussi si ça l'est peut-être qu'il y
avait du talent
du coup il a fait ça pour garder la
colonne de fermer ou pis poupe
mais le problème c'est qu'il a un
contexte fields projet de halle à ses
forces elle je trouve que c'est bien ce
qu'il fait y réfléchit bien çà il prend
son temps parce que mais surtout josiane
d'annahj trois questions surtout il ya
du foncier min version pour le blanc
d'oeuf ou cvt en faire trop vite pour
prêter dame prend le 4 mai sur un mass
lab soins vous c'est vite sinon beaucoup
train de tourner au mythe carrie
bradshaw 8 après d'un point qu'a
apprécié c'est ça y est le sait la chute
la chute en dance marrant parce que
l'ouverture elle était bien qu'il a dû
ce oui mais ça reste en pratique c'est
quand même le bordel quand v6 peut très
vite passé des trucs mois après poopy
poupin comme j'étais aujourd'hui vu
l'arnaqué d'autres dont il faut se
méfier avec lui c'est un joueur aussi
non mais je vais en place à dire faites
m'ont foutu bio s'est jamais fait ça et
on regarde la banane verte qui a 43
points donc en réalité à 1049 c'est vrai
que si l'on gagne encore une rapide il a
le strict il est l'arrêt il peut être à
pareille ensemble à la dernière
et en plus elle fait paraître une erreur
puppy poupe c'est de jouer très vite
venez là peut-être même on t'a toujours
envié de sept ont senti là il a déjà
perdu à mon avis plus d'une minute
trente ans à réfléchir c'est quand même
beaucoup
ouais je crois vraiment tour 17
peut-être on est sage et pas pousser est
ce que on peut juste ne pas manger sur
tours 17
c'est dégueu quand même et peut-être que
c'est vers 3 débutons détroit mais bon
on est tous pareils c'est la grosse
partie du lien commun
ouais je vis à l'étranger attend on peut
aller suivre quand même je suis pour une
deuxième fois à voir s'ils se remet
ouais parce que woerth puis pouf il n'a
pas relancé la partie directe alors
peut-être fou il n'avait pas
d'adversaires et de médias je sais pas
julien qui vire à peine de reprendre
mais à renan ça il peut il peut il peut
se retrouver dans la rate en banane
verte il en est où il joue contre joue
nul et il a il a déjà une pièce de plus
il a quand même plus de 100 points et
l'autre plus doux qui peut gagner assez
vite je suppose et sans faire injure à
notre ami jean bulle pop hip hop ça est
possible qui s'est relancée alors
attends franche de maths pour banane
verte du coût qui devrait les bananes
vertes qui a gagné la guerre ça irait
donc il passe à 48 37 7 47
il a été relancé avant le sprint et
c'est peut-être aller vers ce qui est
plus favoris parce qu'en plus il a un
peu de réussite il vous contraint 1085
si le mot et ça va être chaud mon
parcours est plat qui fait un gros début
de partie il ya une pièce là je vais
bien tout va payer que les français 6 83
qui est français vite et cavalli ressent
à quel point c'est tout
ouais mais ça c'est très bon pour le
noir mais bon ça ça gagne pas sur le
champ oui non c'est faux bien sûr c'est
un énorme avantage mais bon il aurait pu
ça pourrait déjà être avant non ça va
lui faire prendre du temps ouais là
c'est la course on fait ça à deux bandes
presque de qui des adversaires
abandonner les plus rapidement au cir
ouais après j'allais dire il y avait de
la chance cependant ouverte contre
période simonet soi-disant moins fort
mais très solide il lui a fait un
système de londres c'est clair oui je
vois bien besoin de changer l'eau parce
que même déjà il ya plus 19 yens il est
très solide mais à bananes vertes
oui et non il faut bien nous les deux
turbos banane verte la 3000e dis-je
pompiers publicité pareil on sent qu'ils
veulent toujours tempo et vous compris
que ça doit être joué peut-être autant
que ça va forcément là ouais bref qu'ils
fassent pas fou prend ces trois pour
encore plus de matériel
il a du coup il devrait gagner en
agilité
oui mais bon il est encore devant mais
c'est ya rien n'est pas truquée qui
marque deux points la victoire et
bananes vertes en mal on marque quatre
tons qu'au moment où il ya eu tous les
deux ils sont tous les deux à cinq ans
tel qu way et après une autre à trois
points c'est ça et baladeurs pour encore
4 2 il n'était pas favori ces choix mais
jason côté banane verte qui réussit pas
à faire le taf pour le haut bas il joue
vite quoi après l'autre ce n'est pas de
conneries adam prend dès 4 ans
je vais tellement vite que du coup il
rappe des trucs énormément joué des
arénas les arénas entre guillemets
officielle à les arénas king c'est hyper
dur de savoir gérer entre jouer vite
mais à un moment donné savoir que tu
dois pas être un tout petit peu ralentir
il ya un moment critique pour tuer la
partie mais voilà du coup il est aidé
par son adversaire
ouais mais encore courbé un ça va
auquel et youpi coupe ce serait donc et
qui se termine dans la dernière ronde un
petit bout qui pousse balade verte quoi
ce serait cool oui il faudrait que
terminent ensemble avec eux terminent en
même temps ouais ce qui est candidat le
plus probable aux bananes vertes et il a
fait le taf maintenant finir d'être en
même temps c'est chaud ouais ça va finir
à peu près en résistance la dernière
partie les comptabiliser genre là ciel
se termine après les plus jeunes en
phase terminale ça peut être un facteur
ça peut être un facteur auquel tu coupes
qui a gagné du coup il va recommencer à
elle voit un peu avant ce direct ou pas
ah ouais mais il a pris 7 the death cjce
of the beast tu connais ouais et c'est
pas le joueur le faciles du tournoi à
prendre mais baïla 24 déjà les doigts en
plus ton coeur ouais mais il y vraiment
dangereux mais le problème c'est que en
fait si le connaissait il sourit qu'il
faut faire une finale contre cette pub
est allé parce que j'ai finale c'est
vraiment pas son truc mais dans ce genre
de position ils risquent attaquer mais
il est très dangereux
la gêne pas j'aime pas du tout en fait
en voulant jouer vite en accélérant et
tout ils rendent en jeu de 7 de baisse
sous la ive au plus 2006 que 2004 ouais
bah il est pas bien le sens latin
cadalen
4h n'ont que ça va très vite ouais c'est
vrai fait si le connaissent et l'aurait
pas du tout joué comme ça il fallait
faire une partie de ses solides où tu
ferme la porte tu joues stratégique et
petite fille dort c'était une fille dans
la base dont le lait d'attaqué il aurait
pas dû et l'autre côté banane verte qui
va jamais déçu d'avoir un appariement
plus clément donc ils sont traités à 51
mais c'est possible qu'ils aient un
meilleur ratio gain défaite donc c'est
vrai mais devant mais pas nan vertiges
ou iphone à bout des flammes
les shows en fait non ça se termine par
des chocs ça se termine de starmine par
les chocs ouais ils ont les noirs tous
les deux qui à mon avis un peu sa
position elle est ok alors que la
position et les hoquets quoi puis un peu
remonter aussi haut
il est alors il a réussi à ouvrir le
centre ça c'est très bien il a sacrifié
la qualité
ouais mais c'est bien joué et bien joué
ouais c'est sûr que c'est plus il a du
jeu vrai ça va être chaud à l epad une
dame tombée deux intermédiaires dont je
faisais mater sur casse noir de faire
rentrer en 17 sélections dame bk je
mangeais b2c ouais ça va être chaud là
je pense que c'est logique je saute dans
et chic à l'autre un poids
ok banane verte
il a pas mal tu as fait les finales
ouais parce qu'avant il ya encore un an
de ça je le veux à tes d'entre eux
placent à la soul et ça l'a fait
potables impression donc du coup
maintenant il joue assez bien en finale
il va essayer de le travailler au corps
tu assez bien ses coups sage a fait ça
la fait progresser dans perdre bout
ok ça va être dur parce que le résultat
une fois abstenus lula ya pas dans la
dame est défendu en a trois pour le set
il souhaite ouais c'est un claude roy
noir là il était un peu de l'exigeant
ici l oubli poupe ne pas jouer du roi g7
pour avoir du tout âge même si besoin
peut-être tout ce que maintenant ce qui
fait avait annoncé 1 qui pouvaient en
perdre deux trois quatre
jeudi qu'il pouvait s il était quand il
commençait à perdre ah ouais je dis
qu'ils peuvent aussi retournez donc
l'atypique mouille pas encore retourner
si ce n'est pas permis sur damas froid
il fait toi à canal et à chaud que c'est
le seul coup une tour de manche assez
incroyable il était on t'avait dit ouais
si père et tout bon il a quand même
gagné on était là on ne doit en garde le
suspense pourrait au final est plus du
tout favoris du tournoi
non et je pense vraiment honnêtement que
là il doit juste abandonné voyez essayer
de passer à la partie suivante vraiment
ça sert à rien de s'entêter dans son
équipe faisait 5 pour faire bmb bas prix
m
ce qu'il ya combien de cases sur son île
incertain dans quelques regards s'il
avait abondonné l'autre avant qui perd
pas une minute trente exa il a encore
une minute trente en fait tu vois c'est
l'une des raisons et en plus tu peux
tomber contre 1 voire faible ouais moi
il m'est arrivé une fois dans une arena
même plus d'une fois de d'avoir perdu
strict de jouer contre hikaru et
d'abandonner après dix coups pour oui on
a par exemple eu facile passe à autre
chose tout de suite à perdre de temps
quoi ouais alors après évidemment tu ta
ventre et ça je pense que tu joues si tu
joue vraiment pour un aréna pour le
victoire pour le tourisme vers le
tournoi ou stade juste envie de faire
plaisir je suis contre par exemple cas
où
oui ça dépend alors du coup la
demi-finale de pions s'adapte au ghana
ok ça va être c5 le coup je pense alors
là il veut tenter un zoom mais tu peux
faire j'ai six échecs non j'essaie
chaque façon il peut jamais rentrer et
qui m'est fait 6 3 6 3 des 6 regarde sur
les six way
peu importe b6 et maintenant je peux
jamais mais ce que je pourrais rentrer
un moment donné ça la question
je passe sur sept nuls sentiment que ça
doit gagner comme ça mais peut-être que
oui j'y suis c'est intéressant dans
cette finale nous pas se tromper dans la
course que tu vas chercher le b3 ou
faire un gars parce qu'il est pas le
temps de manger de 17 à ce qu ensuite
l'option 6 pour 1 avance mais j'avoue
pas se faire avancer avec g5 c5 et se
retrouve à court de coûts asselah si
pour le coup c'est d'elle c'est janet
est cher ouais euh vous faut aller la
chercher mais tu vas cesser la karma
époux qui pouvaient excusé je passe du
coq à l'âne mais c'est là mon avis très
vraiment une erreur pour la victoire il
vient reviewed claque et ça fait déjà 2
minutes 30 qui claquent dans la position
perdante
il a récupéré quand même qu'elle dit
elle pour moi c'est une mauvaise
stratégie de tourner en aréna ça si vous
voulez jouer la cantate
ilves plus juste les parties par une il
veut moins que le tournant a dit bon ok
je peux sauver la partie cette semaine à
partir
on doit juste prendre la nutrition par
là dessus juste pour l'aréna parce que
vu la situation du tournoi il y aura pas
d'autres parties jouées dans les dents
dans la très chic itunes ou bien de moi
c'est ça et j'étais pas sur la peur et
oui parce que 3 des 6 il a bien car il
manque un temps en blanc bien joué
du coup qu'est ce qu'il a fait comme
conneries récup et blanc j'étais
peut-être foutu mais j'aime et là pour
le coup ça qu'est ce que tu leur dis
haïti de fer affiche 4 way
mais il dit que c'est gagnant gagnant
ok ça peut ça prend ça ça ait changé les
dames vous fait c'est pas salé hockey
dans deux mois le temps pour le trouver
sais pas s'il est très difficile
les pipes ou piste dans le corps ouais
il est pas si l'homme inquiète façon
maintenant partie pour partie pourra
normalement pas gagner autant et c'est
vrai que jusqu'au bout il doit faire le
taf
oui mais il ya peut-être progressisme et
un en autriche où il l'a raté tout
reprend ainsi ce compromis si c'était
beau dans la partie des 5 et 6 ouais il
a quoi puisqu'il ya pas des chats
quelques tours il ya des entreprises
insistent maintenant mais la différence
et qui aura tous invités va se faire
mater qui va peut-être pas le faire il
accuse échec
quoi tu avais raison il a dépensé tout
ce temps pour finalement perdre quand
même ouais et finale sera plus de thon
points ont maintenant il faut il faut
encore trouver le matin il faut encore
trouver le match le roi que ces cinq
mois je reste adapté car ça me weiller
beaucoup plus là c'est typiquement le
truc que tu doutes avec les blancs qui a
un match
mesdames des catalans
on va déjà prendre six échecs et ou 1,8
là oui ça me parait que c'est clairement
la bonne idée le plus simple ouais mais
sera incroyable que ce serait drôle que
la somme à eva rivas la vue et le roi
ses chats wasescha ça va toujours être
gagnant mais non moins si le roi arrive
à se cacher la dame ces quatre là c'est
fort parce que je crois mais cette dame
c'est 8 à huit semaines et sur wade
c'est la dame c'est 8 es tu pour
apprendre aussi c'est un moment donné la
ferme à roanne le prince et gaz de 3,6 à
chaque madame ces huit trois des six
tours des huit d'une telle attaque du
couple époux qui peut la gagner là non
mais c'est fou ce qu'il peut l'arnaqué
c'est là c'est vraiment le contre la
montre parce que il faut qu'il la
gagnante en temps réel la gagne c'est
incroyable on le sait c'est incroyable
mais est-ce que ça suffira pas ce qui
marque un point non et du coup il aura
54 à l'arnaqué mais il sera un point
derrière par 6,7 best fait le truc degen
avis avec le 3 + 2 on peut ne pas la
perdre
oui c'est sûr ouais c'est sûr il va
faire des gains
fall je sais pas si la 33e mais pour
l'instant c'est normal qu'ils jouent on
va voir si cela non non non il va faire
des gosses je passion si tu dois faire
mais je regarde regarde regarde les
grilles du hci dans l'optique du tournoi
tu quoi qu'il en soit tu devais
abandonner parce que là en fait ajouté
six minutes il a fait cesser sa salle
est ce que la partie d'amour s'arrête
moi je pensais que l'abarth continuer
mais qu'elle comptait pas et arrêtent a
dit merci sève de belles toilettes et tu
vois finalement poopy poupe il abandonne
la partie d'avant un peu plus vite
ok mais bon c'était comme bouc finissent
par gagner tout en étant moins 50 est
celle de baisse il est fier de lui écrit
aux portes
ça y est contrarié cantonales elle est
content pourtant il devrait être très
bien avec les 50 go away c'était sale à
ces têtes raides
j'avais dit man différent un peu puis
pouf la crypte qui payent le prix fort
son envie de gemmage apprécié justement
se bat jusqu'au bout oui là il va la
gagner moi je trouve que c'était bon
mais bon c'est le pire scénario qu'il
faut pour le truc du tournant en fait
c'est le pire scénario c'est atroce
d'arnaqué que cette rue continue de
perdre le maximum de temps mais c'est
vrai que 7 de baisse
qu'est ce que tu nous as fait quoi il
est tellement de mal différent que tu as
well as le plus simple c'est quand même
trois si c'était facile
après je pense que tu la gagnes et
tranquille alors vos bananes vers oued
en banane verte au tournoi est fini avec
toi il fait 15 missions 18
ouais 14 il a joué trois parties de plus
quoi ouais il avait déjà fait la
stratégie hp président hu est la
stratégie décalée qui est très risqué
mais quand elle paye à elle fait très
très mal à tout le monde et c'était ça
l'est aussi pour la troisième place à 46
45 au moghreb olaya jeu
non ouais même sont pas loin du décret
bien finalement à et du lien qui fait
tout sur 12 1 1 mais [ __ ] kdg poserait
et 7,2 beast qui finit à 7 sur 8
oui là il a commencé un peu tard parce
que des perf un peu cabot de masques et
on n'a pas vu le résultat de capote
masquer votre qu'à masquer soumis du
cuir finit 3 sur 6
c'est la moyenne je vois pas capote
parce qu on a peut-être un ted voyez
tout au fond c'est juste qu'on pût thing
1 sur 8 c'est vrai mais il a quand même
ils sont moins la main il a marqué son
plein gré je vous jamais en partie
rapide comme ça c'est dur pour lui mais
il a participé c'est plus en plus tu en
étais 115 jean foon nouveau genre clown
3 sur 16 a souffert mais il a mis des
points aussi
ouais il canard le grand maître gims 4
sur 5
ses cheveux faire dès que le rideau qu
il était pas mal oui il était bien placé
à il est assez haut
cette grinta qui a fait 6e gros tournois
mais c'est le black mars à jouer le glac
marc voulait lier des parties progresse
vous échec je voulais blackmar à fond
est carrément s'attendant lillois effet
6e 750 c'est en fait c'est lui la perte
du tournoi et gratins bator aussi à
temps c'est pas malin montez sur 14 et
end ou le maïs aussi du magnus il a
envoyé juste parce qu'à mon avis les
gens après ils te disent mme c'est juste
aussi quand vous avez un plus petit est
lovée contre des joueurs plus faibles
est ce qu'on va vivre sur les battures
un mille huit cent des inscrits
voilà la rainette commencer par
bruxelles donc c'est tout à fait sûr il
a vécu un très sain il a battu en finale
la première ouais il a battu base autres
chaînes sont des joueurs à 1000 lots il
était favori c'est ce qu'ont pu thing
ton copain way qui a commencé à troyes
il a rejoint 1000 après la loi 1200 et à
800 il ya eu des appareils manque havre
la dh ban ki moon
après m il a rejoué lundi ce sens il a
perdu 1 à 15 cents en réalité la
dernière donc il a fait le taf il a fait
une perf quoi mais c'est juste pour vous
dire les gars quand vous dis toi il a un
petit lots il a fini pour moi comment il
fait c'est juste que les os et ce
système
c'est ce qui donne le charme du système
c'est que ça permet à tout le monde de
pouvoir faire une paire de faire le
tournoi ce parti bah oui le fin - qui
écoule est en réalité les plus forts ont
forcément un avantage ce que
j'expliquais souvent aux arénas soyez
oui mais quand tu compte du fait qu'on
ait fait est ce que j'expliquais c'est
que quand éric arnould par exemple tu
vas jouer que condé plus faible mais ça
alors que voilà tout le mag us en fait
il s'est pris une fois publie poupe il
s'est pris une fois en 1900 et même si
son tournoi du coup il a plus de chance
de faire quelque chose malheureusement
pour lui de toute façon à casser ces
rires m'ont donné quoi oui mais oui mais
alors qu'on a vu que tout pipe ou qu'il
aurait pu terminer il fait 14 sur 15 ils
auraient pu faire c'est sur cèze quoi
ils s'éclairent était pas loin du centre
pour son ouïe dire de ne pas gagner 12
ans 14h15 quoi ouais les bananes vertes
il était chaud il a fait le taf banane
verte un bravo bravo à ethan donc de
oued main 13h15 du coup un petit peu
plus tard le tournoi de tokyo lot
bah oui c'est bien 13h15 les gens
mangent tranquille après ils peuvent
faire le tour du web et le franchement
franchement c'était un des lambeaux
tournoi mais je sais pas si après des
candidats pour le moment c'est prévu
c'est qu'on fasse ça sur les nattes des
candidats jusqu'à la fin de l été prévue
mais je sais pas si on va pas continuer
ça jusqu'à la fin du confinement finale
franchement c'est sympa mais en tout cas
je suis je suis chaud pour pour le faire
avec toi ouais ouais c'est simple on
peut on peut on peut carrément tourner
toujours effet réussi avec une fois
alphabet tout faux répond maître le
chien faudrait qu'on se tape concept
tout ça parce que c'était 16h45
française et rebat les oreilles mais bon
on va les bars on va les battre
salut
ouais un petit coup de main je vais déjà
dire impôts qui peuvent devenir douze à
dix ans le ciel histoire qu'on leur
fasse dire mal ce que j'adore jouer
c'est la question qu'on se faisait ce
matin s'est fait discret
on verra dans dix ou douze j'habite sac
radjabov ya très longtemps
il est hyper sympa j'ai discuté avec lui
et tout l'été en mode manuel contre des
points connectés tu me demandes joue
avec toi ok mais c'est plus gênant
connecter ensuite mais ne s'était pas
ouais franchement il était sympa j'aime
parler de tennis avec lui à chacune de
ses sorties et ont dû aller ça marche
elle est là devant tout le monde merci
[Musique]